we are really really psyched about this
our next guest
she is a hollywood triple threat she's
an actor she's a producer she's a
director
what her name is elizabeth banks you may
know her from dozens of scenes stealing
roles like
effie in the hunger games movies and she
produced
and directed the box office hit did you
know this pitch perfect too
now she's adding one more item to her
resume she's a host of the audible
original my body my podcast where
no topic and we do mean no topic is off
limits
elizabeth talks with experts activists
and even her own mom i like this
about things like shame sex and body
image here's the two of them
i recently ordered hundreds of dollars
worth of postcode bathing suits online
we might actually get to see people this
summer and i figured
i know my body by now and what will look
good right and you already know where
this is going
depression and self-loathing those no
returns no refund suits
sit in a drawer reminding me to hate
myself or starve myself or hide myself
and that's essentially what we're
talking about today elizabeth banks
joins us now elizabeth that is so true
there is stuff with your mom we'll talk
about that in just a second
but i have to say i loved your candor i
love your honesty and when i say you go
there
you go all the way there there was even
a little segment about butt bleaching to
be
uh polite here on a morning show i'm not
going to talk about that but i did win
thank you that was very honest and i'm
like no thank you
but you describe yourself as this 5'4
actress blonde kind of funny small boobs
your words not mine
a very nice hip shaker i think you
called it rub shanker
and you said it wasn't until your 30s
that you really even started paying
attention
and noticing other societal forces at
work what happened what
talk talk about your body evolution for
yourself
oh wow i mean it's such a frock question
kill
of course uh you know i i'm
i'm a mom now i'm raising two boys and
and really i think
so much of what in what went into the
podcast
came about because i felt like i didn't
have
the tools to talk to them about these
exact things that you're asking me about
and how to prepare them to not have a
shame and stigma
around their own bodies around talking
about other people
how to have these discussions and how to
think about sex
our bodies and our sexuality as part of
our holistic humanity and not
something to be siloed off and only
talked about in secret and in the
shadows and
um it really came down to that having
just more and more experiences
and being more and more open about my
myself this is the most personal thing
i've ever done in my life
um making this podcast and i
i did it with the intention of sort of
improving
conversation around all of these things
with
my friends my family myself and even as
you say with my own mom i know i love
the thing with your mom i i felt
i became very smitten with your mom but
i love too
that you take on things like your first
sexual experience for instance
you you talk about having your first
period which i have to say i was really
glad you did that because when i got
mine i thought i was dying
nobody had ever talked to me about it
ever and so when i went to my
grandmother because my mom wasn't home
at the time she goes oh
you have to wait till your mom comes
home i go well she's not coming home for
two days
i mean so just the fact that you laid it
out in a very
um understandable way to let people know
you're not alone when this stuff happens
to you
and we do need to talk about starting
with your own mom who didn't even know
how to pronounce the word
you say it wait
your mom your mom oh
[Laughter]
she says other words on the podcast too
so but but i was like i can't say those
on cbs this morning
yes you can
but what was funny is that your mom was
pronouncing it vagina and your mom
has been married with three kids and it
was a man that told her you know you're
saying it wrong
yeah i have had these conversations with
so many women across my life
and you know even friends and college
roommates who
uh i had a college roommate who would
not wash herself
without a washcloth because she was told
that touching her body with her own hand
was shameful and i these these things
break they just
they break my heart and um i really felt
like this was just so
my small way of making these kinds of
conversations
just more normal just normal to have you
know these just our bodies we can take
the power
away from all of these words by just
using them correctly
and talking about them freely and um i'm
hoping that it creates a
a a you know a
tool for other people listen elizabeth
it's anthony you mentioned your two sons
and and that you you kind of started
this because you wanted to figure out
how to approach
talking to them about all these societal
expectations
have you figured out kind of how to do
that
i'm still working on it i'm still
learning um you the main thing for me is
start early it's not one conversation
it's multiple conversations um
that their safety and their well-being
is actually entwined
with so much of it and i think when you
think about your job as a parent being
your child your children's safety and
approaching it from
that place like this makes them safer in
the world if they know these things if
they know what their body parts are
if they can talk about them openly
they're much less likely to be abused
they're much
less likely to have an unintended
pregnancy
all the things that you fear you can
actually um help allay
if you just have these conversations
early and often
and as i i say and i say this to my mom
too you need to have trusted
adults in your life when you're young
people that you can go
to with any questions and it doesn't
even have to be
you so if you're like maybe ask your
auntie about that or your grandmother
for gayle you know like just knowing
that
my kids have trusted adults that's what
matters to me
elizabeth eureka duncan here and
obviously you want people to take away a
lot from that podcast but i do want to
turn to
what you are in ireland for right now
which is uh the direct directing cocaine
bear tell us a little bit about that
yes thank you i'm i am i'm in dublin
ireland
i'm about to start a film here cocaine
bear
uh in in in a real life story in 1985
a bear consumed 17
million dollars worth of cocaine
and uh we start our story there and we
imagine
the chaos that would happen if i bear in
the wilderness
in chattahoochee uh national forest
had consumed a bunch of cocaine and what
that what chaos may ensue from that
um and on all the people that come
across the bears
path that day uh in 1985. it was dropped
out of a plane right is that what
happened
it was it was yeah it was a a notorious
drug smuggler's
mo was to drop bags of drugs out of
airplanes they'd get picked up on the
ground and he would
uh dump the planes in the ocean um
and this one went sideways the guy died
so
everybody knew that the drugs were in
the woods and so this is all it's a big
like sort of a caper movie
uh but there's a bear high on cocaine in
the middle of it
it's hard to think that is a true story
congrats to you elizabeth for your
podcast and being back in the director's
chair
please know we are cheering you on
really great great thank you guys so
much
great to see you thank you my body my
podcast is available exclusively on
audible